acer is a quote on your IMDB page and it
says I'll never be satisfied by the
thought of being summoned with quote a
lot of potential yeah you probably all
know very talented people in this town
and we grew up with that had a lot of
potential right nothing ever came of it
and it doesn't seem like you leave
things to chance you seem very proactive
to me just in the short time I've met
you so is this part of your secret to
being someone that just won't leave
things simply the chance you really
attack an opportunity you see it yeah
you know I um I defend me thanks for
mentioning that you know it's always
kind of good to just be reminded of you
know of something like that um yeah that
word potential always just it's sort of
scary to me you know and and I I can't
remember when it was that I sort of made
that connection but uh you know I think
that idea of just being at the best
someone with a lot of potential yeah I
mean it's like you know if I died
tomorrow and he said well he had a lot
of potential I mean that I would break
my heart you don't mean I hear that
about anybody um so yeah I you know I
there's so much that I can't control we
can't control you know there's so much
out of our control so I'd like to be
able to be proactive and take more I
guess just more control over what what I
can do you know for myself and and and
for a product um so that's always in the
back of my head of you know what we what
I can be doing to sort of further that
and I think I've met like you said a lot
of people and I mean even personally
like one of the things that always
drives me you know in doing this and I
was tell people I'm like you know if I
woke up one day and for some weird
reason I was like I'm drawn to a man
even know you know like painting street
signs or something you know if that's
what it was that I felt I would be happy
with doing then that's what I'm gonna do
you know and I know nothing else aside
from being an entertainment that that
you know that that just inspires me and
is like that's what I want to do when I
grow up that that meant how
you know and like you know seeing
members of my family and even as close
to Mike my myself as my dad who you know
my dad was just somebody who he always
it was so simple he wanted to be a heel
he would have loved to just be a gym
teacher he's a former athlete and you
know it was a was a great athlete you
know I had all these opportunities for
colleges and stuff like that and um you
know he i guess he I remember growing up
and he was like oh I just I'd love to
just be a gym teacher should be able to
to you know teach and coach kids and
sports and all that type of stuff and
and my dad was a crane operator and he
managed you know a big team and stuff
and and I just always remember thinking
as a kid that you know I never want to
do something you know for work that I I
didn't look forward to you know and and
and he did that because he had to
provide for us and no for our family and
then he did that without you no worry or
complaint and so that's just something
that always spoke to me you know and I
saw their family members doing you know
the same you know in their own way like
just doing what they had to do you know
not necessarily what they wanted to do
and I think that's one of the things
where I'm lucky that my parents push and
and encourage me so much to to do what I
wanted to do so you know that potential
sort of ties into that you know like my
dad had potential to do these other
things that he wanted to do but sort of
in a way that was you know hehe the best
thing that he had was being a good
father to us you know and I could
provided to us so so yeah I always I
that's a big message that I always kind
of try to remind myself of and I and I
just like to share with people and even
with people that I work with you know
like we always talked about that but
just our product it's like our film like
I don't want it to be I don't want the
script to be this film had a lot of
potential you know like we have to do
what we can to make it go beyond that
you know and and and rise above that so
I do try to bring that to you know to
whatever i'm working on or whoever i'm
working with what do you think that
isn't someone that sits on potential
let's say that they don't have children
they're living a free life maybe they're
even debt free so they really don't have
a lot of responsibility and they're
extremely talented and they just sit on
I've never seen so many people not
totally but I know that it breaks my
heart because I wish I had what they had
but right now and then you see them find
all these excuses and they don't do
anything mm-hmm you know it's tough like
I I mean I'd be a hypocrite if I if I
didn't say at some point um you know I
don't actively pursue something every
minute every second of my life i mean
i'm lazy as much as anybody can't be i'm
even being you know but um i don't know
i mean i think everybody's different you
know it depends like you know people
talk to me all the time I from these
coasts you know know like what do you
think about New York would you ever move
back and and my answer is always like I
would love to move back and one day plan
to but I would never do it at this stage
of where I'm at in my life and career um
because AI think there's just more
opportunity for me here as a as a career
you know in Los Angeles and be like I
would just want to be more comfortable
living in New York and and um you know
because New York's a tough city and it
has different challenges and there's
pros and cons to both la in New York you
know I don't think he apples and oranges
you can't compare um but for me it's
like I wouldn't want to grind it out
back in New York again you know like I
do like that you know i can walk outside
with 60 degrees you know but that also
provides a setting where it's easy to
sort of be laid back as we all know you
know in los angeles and it's interesting
i just took a class there's a commercial
class and the teacher he was you know he
was sort of giving us examples of the
message was just using every opportunity
as as you know a launching pad just the
best that you can make of it you know
and he would always talk about Meryl
Streep and he's just like you know Meryl
Streep can do three lines on on any TV
show or a commercial or lead in the film
or reading the phone book and you we all
expect Meryl Streep you know we she's
somebody that you can't say she's not
she's gonna phone it in you know she's
gonna give it you know what I mean and
then and at his point it was just like
you guys have to give it for
thing whether it's a commercial whether
it's this weather it's that and he would
like he was saying you know because then
you get to a point where you know maybe
they're in your mid-30s or whatever it
is whatever age and you want to have a
family and you want to start doing
things and you need a real person job
because you need to supply you know
you're provide for for those things and
that's where sometimes we know like
people who start to UM just leave the
business or to step away from it in ways
you know and that kind of hit me I was
like wow that's really true but
furthermore like he was saying you know
there are people who who will come to
the city or live in this city will come
from money so that's not a concern for
them you know they don't have to push
past you know working at a starbucks
McDonald's whatever it is you know not
to judge but just you know a harder um
you know straight job you know they
don't have to worry about it you know so
they can go out there and and and sort
of recklessly um you know go on their
auditions or just go through whatever it
is that they're doing in a weird way his
message was you know we have to bring
that to you know like that sense of not
being attached to it because they don't
have they don't have to be attached to
it because at the end of the day they're
billed or paid for you know what I mean
where's I'll go in or somebody else will
go in and were like we really need this
job or we want this job to be able to
pay bills or whatever it is you know
whatever the person's situation is and
you know just relating those two things
so I think it's different for everybody
because i think you know if somebody
doesn't have to worry about paying bills
then they can go out there and sort of
be reckless and sometimes those are the
best auditions you know because you
don't care you know now what they have
the drive to keep going um and and and
continuing along I don't know you know
because that's also something that
someone that is hungry you know will
have you know cuz they don't want to be
stuck you know waiting tables all all
their career here in LA so I don't know
I don't think there's a really a
specific answer for that but but there
are different scenarios that we're just
placed in you know out of our control
that we just kind of have to I guess
learn how to navigate and I think it's
there's always going to be challenged
for everybody I don't think anybody's
necessarily gifted into one way or not
you know even i know people give the
showgirls you know flak because they
sort of come from families who are
established in their own way don't like
well yeah but their parents are these
people or whatever but still that's a
hurdle for them to overcome in a way and
I'm sure there are people out there like
the critics that are giving them a hard
time that they you know that that
becomes a challenge for them to sort of
win people over in their own way so I
don't think it's fair to sort of judge
anybody's input you know um you know
specific journey I guess
you